If it was, like, bring in
a bunch of black people,
racism test.
I probably wouldn't watch
that video,
but when I hear, like,
we're gonna give all
your white colleagues
racism tests,
I'm definitely watching
that video.
This season on "Glad You Asked,"
across five episodes
we're gonna explore
how racial injustice
impacts everything
from education to housing.
In your lease it would say,
"You cannot resell to a black
family."
- Yeah.
- But first, in order to better
understand those systems,
we need to think about
our own biases
and what role
they play.
Is having racial preferences
in dating racist?
- Yeah.
- Dum-dum-dum.
How do we even start to talk
about solutions
to health disparities
that come from
such structural
inequalities?
I just felt like most of the
time I was trying to
survive.
How do we measure
our own biases?
Do you guys think
this machine is racist?
Does your neighborhood
determine your future?
If merit isn't just about
ability and effort,
why are we still obsessed
with merit?
How does the stress of
discrimination impact
people's bodies?
And most importantly,
what can we do about it?
I don't want your question
to be, "How racist am I?"
I want your question to be,
"What can I do affirmative?"